ça c'est très touchant seule dame de la
semaine je veux juste qui fait ma vie
sans votre jugement je vous dis qui
s'est enfoncé loup voilà c'est le coup
de gueule effectivement de louer père
noël a poussé un coup de gueule sur tik
tok regarder
[Musique]
sans cela
à c
voilà et est conforme à celle autre
vidéo s'il y en a une très minuad aussi
où elle parle de la du décès de son père
je cautionne pas je sais pas parce que
je me tenais que je vais mettre que je
fais pas mal parce que je montre que je
souris que je suis pas triste
en fait je sais pas ce que vous voulez
jardon notre côté genre je sais pas tu
veux quoi tu veux quoi me retrouve
quatuor fait si ton but c'est de le voir
chialer toute la journée swype commande
pas mais tik tok genre ne soutient pas
ta bonne pas et commente pas ce genre je
veux pas de personnes comme tron qui me
suivent je veux communauté good life
c'est bon parfois donc non jury tu as
bien et je suis très mal pour te dire
j'ai passé ma journée à chialer parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça devait être à jeun
jeter d'anniversaire ok
je veux dire inquiet qu'avant la presse
que j'y arriverai pas jean pierre
pernaut et ça va être très compliqué de
réagir quoi tout savoir je poursuis mon
machin en fait c'est super compliqué de
réagir c'est la même problématique que
simon casas envie de dire pardon louté
adorable t'es gentil va faire des études
quoi bosse mais elle est surtout stock
de pierres non mais pardon je suis je
suis cash j'embrasse sa maman nathalie
et franchement je suis désolé de dire ce
que je vais dire mais s'ils voulaient
que la vérité voilà ccta mauvaise voie
quoi continuer leurs ayants
droits excuse parce que jean pierre est
mort ya pas longtemps que globalement h
un pardon mais génération en or puisque
ce que je vois c'est pas très digne
pardon loup c'est pas trés dire et je
pense que tu devrais depuis la porte on
perd calmer un peu les tic toc les
machins erfurt est où travaillent
il n'y a pas longtemps ils ont fêté ce
que radio est l'anniversaire cellulaire
et c'est vrai que tout ça a été mise sur
instagram sur tectum oui pardon il ya
des gens qui disent un peu de pudeur
vives entre vous tous ne se vit pas à
travers l'image quand les gens vont
voyager ils font que des photos et
rentrent chez eux et regarde si vous
restez à voyager et après on s'étonne
que lui soient mal on va s'étonner dans
un nom qu'elles sont encore plus mal on
va s'étonner qu'on va les faire parler
sur le fait qu'elle soit mal et elle va
être encore plus mal alors lui donnant
pas l'art qui sommes nous aujourd'hui
pour savoir comment les gens doivent ou
pas vivre ce qu'ils valent mais à notre
avis
mecheri j'entends très tôt totalement ce
que tu dit laurent mais maintenant c'est
très dur de regarder la télé d'entendre
la d'entendre dire par un ami un ami de
son défunt père ma chérie retour de fer
dont le ton c'est bon c'est sûr je
repars de zéro moi je trouve ça
innommable il ya des gens qui pensent
gagner les jo normal il ya des gens qui
pensent mais qui pense chez eux c'est
une gamine qui a perdu son père et qui a
le droit de continuer à vivre en cfa
tellement ça fait peur je sais aussi
c'est à dire c'est un peu de points
qu'on se moque d'elle sur le sait pas
que c'est toujours moqué d'elle et maman
demande juste aux gens de lui [ __ ] la
paix moi c'est une petite que je trouve
qu étaient les shadows mama
à ludivine que comme alors en trois
choses la première déjà elle décide
d'être influence euse donc quand tes
influences euse que tu vas sur tik tok
instagram et cetera tu t'exposes à ça
donc ça déjà si tu ne veux pas
l'accepter ne s'expose pas point final
ensuite son père vient de mourir
effectivement c'est très triste mais
c'était une personne publique qui d'une
certaine façon appartenait aux français
donc elle peut pas empêcher que ce genre
de réactions ci est d'ailleurs même sa
mère le dit sa mère vient de donner une
interview au parisien en disant que
certifie les canards jeux films
terminés les semaines terminé sa mère
dit quand elle est en déplacement pour
le théâtre etc c'est elle qui consolent
les gens c'est elle qui consolent les
gens qui viennent pleurer dans ses bras
sa mère le 10 mai m
je dis pas qu'ils ont raison de
l'insulté et de se moquer d'elle je dis
juste que les ridules exposé à ça c'est
un peu les règles du jeu
et pour tout les et marcel mailhot j
hallucine lorient vient la bêtise n'est
pas lorient du zen c'est des connards le
cyber le cyberharcèlement c'est quelque
chose qui est aujourd'hui et je le conte
un peu qu'on peut le compo unir sûr on
va pas arrêter de se mettre sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que y'a des
connards qui nous traitent de gros de
moche parce que j'étais trop comme ça
t'es trop comme ça la tic toc c'est un
peu inquiétant parce que c'est une
plateforme qui est principalement pour
les jeunes et les commentaires moi j'y
suis alors que je pus très jeune belge
devrait on m'enlevait tip top parce que
ces géants de la mer dom le total des
plus habillés c'est vraiment de la merde
et les commentaires sur tik tok qui sont
mais c'est aux lancers pire que twitter
s'est tue c'est inquiétant c'est
inquiétant
je réponds à florian mais ça veut dire
qu'en fait tu ne peux être sur les
réseaux sociaux que si tes mains ces
belles nom du toit depuis pékin ont tué
puis devient influente young ha situés
un peu solides dont abdel un
noah qui est dessus non mais alors moi
je suis pas sûr qu il toque jeu
seulement soir mais il faut savoir aux
jeunes qui nous regarde là je parle à
eux vous savez vous êtes protégé sur les
réseaux sociaux si toutefois vous avez
des injures en permanence que ce soit
public sur facebook instagram ou twitter
celui qui fait les injures peut avoir
six mois de prison jusqu'à 22 1500 euros
damende alors jamais sa chambre de motel
et du tricot toi tu es malheureux oui
mais quand tu à son âge et que tu
essaies tous conçus rdc ton père tu es
né sous le feu des projecteurs tu es la
fille de nathalie pernaut tout ça c'est
très difficile pour elle de ses
retraités gonzalez le dit comment tu
veux qu'elle ait de l'assuré dans les
tic il ya pas mal et ça c'est pas ça
fausse organisé
et c'est pas fini gellé je bosse et
instagram
si vous passez mais qu'on n'a pas loupé
renouer toi toi c'est ton top un
personnage mais deux spectacles à 14 ans
qui se vident look c'est juste la foule
et hafid et la fine du présentateur du
13h et latino benjamin castaldi non les
jeunes
on est plus au début des réseaux sociaux
n'est plus on n'est plus maintenant dix
ans que ça existe elle c'est chaud ou 15
ans on sait des conséquences donc si
t'as pas un minimum de forme accomplie
commerçants que tu valeo prendre des
tombereaux ami que tu
n'as pas 15 1 700 patients sur elle à 17
et elle a une maman et elle avait un
papa
jean pierre qui fait le rsa qu'elle se
serait pas ce que tu dis pardon parce
que tu m'as alors là tu as déjà gelé
isabelle à paris isabelle chauriens en
clôture un moment donné faut stopper la
machine parce que c'est la bouteille à
lampard dont je dis ça tu me réponds ça
je dis ça que tu me réponds ça a
abandonné faut savoir décéléré un petit
peu pour justement le plus exposé au
temps ça veut pas dire ne plus y être du
tout ça veut dire qu'il ya quand même
mais dont le tapis d'amis les jeunes
vivent de ça se monte type et
j'attendais mes enfants me regarder la
télé belle aux pyrénées mais l envie pas
puisqu'elle est malheureuse elle le dit
elle-même arrête un mais elle n'était
pas grande victoire qu'elle l'est parce
que sur ben elle l'était pas avant
tictoc bas ne fait pas tik tok c'est
probable
mais s'ils sont pas seuls à fondre mais
martin les filles sont pas besoin d'un
dieu mais gérard gens d'arrêter
d'harceler s'est pas ouvert
ces médailles sur ses amis avec georges
ampli casque faut s'en servir
je réponds à ce que tu m'as dit parce
que mes fait qu'on joue oui je fais très
très court évidemment quand elle est
victime de gros sauts fobis et c'est
condamnable en tout point et c'est
scandaleux d'un mois je ne parlais pas
de ça je parlais de tous les reproches
que lui font ses followers qui lui
disent comment peux-tu apparaître aussi
heureuse art vient de perdre ton papa
c'est les reproches qu'elle reçoit
depuis des semaines des mois je parle
uniquement de ça jeudi jusque
effectivement quand tu es un personal un
personnage public et que tu es la fille
d'un des français les plus connus de
l'histoire de la télévision tu t'exposes
hassar
et ex de côté parce que toutes les
économies
samedi ça mais comme chez animateurs ce
sera le mot de la fin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]